Bonjour à tous et bienvenue !
Cette vidéo est sponsorisée par le jeu vidéo The Architect : Paris, développé par le studio français Enodo.
Ce jeu vous permet de modifier les quartiers de la ville de Paris au gré de vos envies. La ville a été reproduite en 3D par deux architectes qui sont à l’origine de ce projet.
Contrairement à d’autres jeux de construction de villes, vous ne partez pas de zéro, mais de la ville que vous connaissez
Il s’agit de l’adapter et de la transformer selon votre propre vision : écologique, historique, futuriste, etc..
En plus, pour une fois, ce ne sont pas des villes à l’américaine qu’on vous propose de construire,
avec des avenues et des gratte-ciels,
mais vous aurez la possibilité de refaçonner complètement les façades anciennes, les immeubles haussmanniens
et tous les bâtiments emblématiques de la capitale.
The Architect Paris est maintenant disponible dans sa version complète sur Steam
alors n’hésitez pas si vous aimez l’histoire et l’architecture, c’est hyper-réaliste et satisfaisant,
nous on a adoré.
Aujourd’hui je vous propose un format un peu
inédit. Plutôt que de faire découvrir la vie
et le travail de quelqu’un d’assez peu connu
chez nous comme on l’a fait avec Margaret Mead,
dans cette vidéo
on va faire exactement le contraire. Je voudrais
revenir sur des chercheurs en sciences humaines
que vous connaissez forcément et expliquer
pourquoi ils sont incontournables. En fait,
c’est un peu une vidéo en forme de rappel mais
vous allez voir que ça fait pas de mal parce
qu’à force d’entendre leur nom partout sans
qu’on nous réexplique jamais leur travail,
on finit par ne plus vraiment savoir ce qu’on
leur doit. On va donc essayer de synthétiser
l’apport réel de quatre penseurs incontournables
dans leur champ de recherche : sociologie,
anthropologie, archéologie et histoire.
J’ai bien conscience que c’est un
exercice pratiquement impossible de résumer en
quelques minutes des vies entières de travail,
d’autant plus lorsqu’il s’agit des plus
brillants universitaires contemporains.
Cette vidéo n’a donc absolument pas la prétention
de faire une synthèse complète de leurs œuvres,
mais plutôt de mettre en évidence les
points les plus marquants de leurs
travaux de vous donner des pistes
pour approfondir. Question : est-ce
qu’un live lecture de passages choisis
sur Instagram pour prolonger la vidéo
vous intéresse ? Dites-le en commentaires.
Emile Durkheim est né en 1858 à Epinal dans les
Vosges. Dans sa famille, on est rabbin de père en
fils depuis des générations, mais Emile va déroger
à la règle. Après une classe préparatoire au lycée
Louis-le-Grand et l’Ecole Normale supérieure,
Durkheim est agrégé de philosophie. La voie royale
de l’intellectuel français. Mais Durkheim s’écarte
de la philosophie. Il choisit de rédiger une thèse
de sociologie sur la division du travail. Il
considère en effet que la philosophie est trop
éloignée des problématiques de son temps. Plutôt
que de philosopher sur des notions abstraites,
il veut participer au progrès social grâce
à la science. Cet héritage lui vient tout
droit de la pensée d’Auguste Comte, qui a
d’ailleurs inventé le terme de sociologie.
Durkheim donne à Bordeaux à partir de 1887 les
premiers cours de sociologie dans une université
française. Il fonde aussi la revue L’Année
sociologique en 1898 qui cristallise autour
d’elle de nombreux jeunes chercheurs, notamment
grâce à son neveu Marcel Mauss, l’un des grands
noms de l’ethnologie française. A partir de
1902, Durkheim enseigne la sociologie à Paris,
à la Sorbonne, et poursuit son effort pour ancrer
cette nouvelle discipline, l’institutionnaliser.
En homme pressé, il veut mettre rapidement
la science au service du progrès social.
Et pour faire ça, il donne à la sociologie un
objet d’étude : les faits sociaux. Durkheim
définit un fait social comme un fait réel, qui
existe en dehors des individus. Il dit en 1895
dans les Règles de la méthode sociologique que les
faits sociaux sont “des choses”. Une formule-choc
qui a fait couler beaucoup d’encre. En disant
cela, Durkheim explique qu’on peut les appréhender
de l’extérieur, qu’on n’a pas besoin d’être dans
la tête des gens pour comprendre la société. Il
distingue donc la sociologie de la psychologie.
Il étudie notamment le suicide, délaisse les
aspects psychologiques ou philosophiques et
montre, statistiques à l’appui, que des facteurs
sociaux peuvent expliquer le phénomène. Si on se
suicide plus chez les ruraux que chez les urbains,
ou chez les protestants que chez les catholiques,
c’est que des phénomènes sociaux entrent en jeu.
Et pour mettre en lumière les influences de la
société, Durkheim utilise la méthode comparative,
qui est « l’équivalent pour la science
sociale de ce qu’est l’expérimentation
dans les sciences de la nature ».
En lui fournissant un objet et
une démarche propre, Durkheim fait de la
sociologie une discipline à part entière,
le titre de « père de la sociologie », qu’on lui
décerne souvent, n'est donc pas usurpé. D’autant
que son apport ne s’arrête pas là. Dans sa thèse,
De la division du travail social, publiée en 1893,
il avait déjà théorisé une grande séparation entre
les sociétés humaines. Celles qui possèdent une
solidarité “mécanique”, les plus primitives,
et celles où la solidarité est “organique”,
les nôtres. Le passage de l’une à l’autre découle
selon lui de la division du travail. Dans nos
sociétés, chacun exécute une tâche spécialisée,
à la manière d’un organe, et dépend des autres,
ce qui renforcerait la solidarité.
Son travail sur la religion est
aussi particulièrement fécond. Dans Les
Formes élémentaires de la vie religieuse,
en 1912, Durkheim aborde la religion comme
un phénomène avant tout social. Il analyse
le phénomène religieux à partir des notions
de sacré et de profane, une distinction qui
est toujours au cœur de son étude aujourd’hui.
Emile Durkheim s’éteint en 1917, à seulement 59
ans. Une partie de ses disciples est décimée
dans les tranchées de la Grande Guerre, et la
sociologie française en est durablement affectée.
Au XXe siècle, sa sociologie tournée vers la
recherche de l’ordre et son rejet de la lutte
des classes lui ont valu d’être considéré comme
un bourgeois conservateur. Pourtant l’œuvre
de Durkheim porte bien un projet de réforme
de la société, seulement elle est graduelle
et raisonnée, pas révolutionnaire. Un peu à
la manière de Jaurès, dont il était proche.
Quoi qu’il en soit, l’influence de la pensée
de Durkheim est considérable en sciences humaines.
Lorsque l’anthropologie a voulu se débarrasser des
théories biologiques et évolutionnistes, elle
a trouvé dans les faits sociaux de Durkheim
une opportunité de se transformer.
Claude Lévi-Strauss est né à Bruxelles en 1908, et
grandit à Paris où il fait une classe préparatoire
et passe l’agrégation de philosophie, super
original. Son mariage en 1932 avec l’ethnologue
Dina Dreyfus l’initie à l’anthropologie. En
1935, il est invité à enseigner la sociologie
à l’université de Sao Paulo. Et il profite de ses
années brésiliennes pour se rendre chez plusieurs
peuples amérindiens : Caduvéos, Bororos, Tupis
et Nambikwaras. Interdit d’enseignement par les
lois antisémites de Vichy, il embarque pour
les Etats-Unis en 1941. A New York où il a
trouvé un poste d’enseignant, il rencontre parmi
les plus brillants esprits de l’époque. Il fait
connaissance notamment de Franz Boas, qu’on
a évoqué dans la vidéo sur Margaret Mead, et
aussi de Roman Jakobson qui lui fait découvrir la
linguistique structurale qui l’inspire énormément.
De retour en France à la fin de la guerre, il
soutient sa thèse d’anthropologie, publiée en
1949 sous le nom de Structures élémentaires de la
parenté. C’est une œuvre majeure. Dans ce texte,
il explore une intuition qu’il a eue, à savoir
que l’interdit de l’inceste est présent dans
toutes les sociétés humaines et qu’il les
force à échanger avec autrui. C’est pour
lui ce qui sépare nature et culture. Ce travail
s’intéresse en détail aux systèmes d’échanges
de femmes. Il étudie les règles qui obligent
dans certaines sociétés un homme à épouser
une femme en particulier. Lévi-Strauss met
ainsi en évidence une logique sous-jacente,
des structures générales, et cette méthode
est popularisée sous le nom de structuralisme.
Le structuralisme c’est en fait plus une méthode
d’analyse qu’une doctrine. C’est chercher les
opérations de pensée qui créent les faits sociaux.
En distinguant quelques opérations (opposition,
analogie, contraste) et quelques éléments de
base on doit pouvoir aboutir à toutes les formes
d’organisation sociale connues. On peut ainsi, selon Lévi-Strauss,
révéler des invariants et accéder à la nature
profonde de l’esprit humain. C’est ce qu’il va
poursuivre toute sa vie durant. Dans les années
qui suivent, de nombreux autres ethnologues se
lancent dans une étude similaire des systèmes
de mariage dans toutes les sociétés du monde.
En 1955 paraît Tristes tropiques, son ouvrage
le plus littéraire et le moins théorique,
et qui lui assure un succès mondial. Récit
mi-autobiographique, mi-sociologique,
il est traduit en 26 langues et reste un classique
absolu de la littérature. En 1958, il publie
Anthropologie structurale, un recueil d’articles
où il applique sa méthode structurale à de
nombreux domaines : langage, religion, art… Grâce
à cela, il est élu en 1959 au Collège de France où
il inaugure une chaire d’anthropologie sociale.
Ce nouvel environnement de travail dope sa
productivité. En 1962, Lévi-Strauss publie Le
totémisme aujourd’hui dans lequel il brise le
mythe d’une religion originelle totémiste, et
surtout La Pensée sauvage. Je veux m’arrêter un
peu sur ce livre, et pas uniquement parce qu’il
a inspiré le nom de la chaîne YouTube. Dans ce
livre, qui est parfois considéré comme le plus
marquant de la deuxième moitié du XXe siècle,
Lévi-Strauss dynamite la notion de “peuple
primitif”. A cette époque, les anthropologues
avaient encore du mal à expliquer pourquoi les
peuples qu’ils étudiaient tenaient des discours
aussi irrationnels, affirmant par exemple être les
enfants des animaux de la forêt, ou expliquant le
monde par des mythes qui n’ont ni queue ni tête.
Lévi-Strauss dans cet ouvrage assez… ardu il faut
le dire, démontre qu’il n’y absolument pas de
confusion mentale de la part de ces peuples,
mais au contraire des opérations intellectuelles
d’analogie et de contraste, des transformations
logiques qui forment une structure cohérente.
Ne lisez pas la Pensée sauvage avant Tristes tropiques
Ne faites pas ça chez vous
Quitte à avoir un fond "bibliothèque" autant assumer un peu
et vous sortir 2/3 trucs
C'est pas que de la mise en scène, ça sert aussi
Cet ouvrage réfute donc la hiérarchie entre les cultures et Lévi-Strauss acquiert une notoriété
gigantesque.
La portée phénoménale de cette révélation en fait un incontournable et chaque
courant philosophique, marxisme, existentialisme,
etc., doit désormais se positionner face au
« structuralisme » de Claude Lévi-Strauss.
De 1964 à 1971, il s’attelle à une autre analyse
structurale, celle des mythes amérindiens,
publiée en 4 volumes et plus de 2000 pages. Deux
autres volumes de ces Mythologiques viendront
s’ajouter en 1985 et 1991. C’est un travail
absolument colossal, qui consiste à comparer
des milliers de mythes, pour déterminer
leurs liens, et finalement aboutir à une
clé de lecture universelle de tous les mythes. Une
application magistrale de la méthode structurale.
En 1973, dans La Voie des masques, il applique
la même méthode avec l’art amérindien de la côte
Nord-ouest. A quatre-vingts-ans passés, il
continue de travailler et de s’intéresser à
tous les arts et les sciences de son
temps, mathématiques, informatique,
psychologie, littérature… Érudit complet et
intellectuel français le plus influent du
siècle, il meurt quelques jours avant son
101ème anniversaire, le 30 octobre 2009.
André Leroi-Gourhan nous sert ici à illustrer
l’archéologie mais vous allez le voir, son
travail touche aussi à l'anthropologie,
et c’est sans doute la raison pour
laquelle son œuvre est aussi pérenne.
Né à Paris en 1911, André Leroi-Gourhan est
orphelin de père à 4 ans et est élevé par ses
grands-parents maternels. Pas très doué pour
l’école, il la quitte à 14 ans et commence
à travailler. Pas de prépa, pas d’agreg de
philo donc…
Nan mais comme quoi c'est possible !
Leroi-Gourhan collectionne des objets du monde entier dès l’adolescence en
fréquentant les marchés aux puces de Paris, il
lit énormément et se met à fréquenter les écoles
d’anthropologie et de Langues orientales. C’est
là qu’il devient d’ailleurs aide bibliothécaire
et reprend des études. Après un diplôme de russe,
un autre de chinois, et une licence de
lettres, il suit l’enseignement de Marcel
Mauss au musée d’ethnographie du Trocadéro.
Il est rapidement chargé d’y organiser une
exposition sur les Eskimos (aujourd’hui on dit
Inuit), dont il est devenu à force de lecture
et de collection, un éminent spécialiste.
Sa première publication est La Civilisation
du renne en 1936. Leroi-Gourhan n’a encore que 25
ans mais il dessine déjà les perspectives qui vont
le guider toute sa vie durant. En étudiant les
techniques, il croise les époques et les lieux.
Il rapproche les chasseurs du Paléolithique
européen et les éleveurs de Sibérie actuelle,
en partant de leur relation commune avec les
rennes. Il prend en compte toutes les données,
climat, comportement animal, artisanat, mythologie
et envisage les peuples de la Préhistoire comme
des civilisations à part entière.
La guerre ne freine pas son activité.
Leroi-Gourhan passe les années d’occupation à
travailler d’arrache-pied et sera aussi décoré
pour son engagement dans la Résistance. Il publie
entre 1943 et 1945 les deux tomes de sa première
œuvre capitale Evolution et Techniques. Ces
deux livres constituent une percée importante
dans l’étude de la technologie en introduisant
notamment le concept de chaîne opératoire dont
j’ai déjà parlé dans une précédente vidéo.
A la Libération, il soutient sa thèse et est
nommé professeur d’ethnologie à la faculté de
Lyon. Pas mal pour un gars qui a quitté l’école
à 14 ans. C’est à Lyon que Leroi-Gourhan commence
à pratiquer l’archéologie de terrain. Il organise
en effet des chantiers archéologiques destinés aux
étudiants. Ses fouilles préhistoriques ont pour
objectif d’appliquer la méthode des ethnologues
à l’archéologie et ainsi rapprocher les deux
disciplines. Les vestiges matériels, s’ils sont
bien étudiés, révèlent selon lui les mentalités et
les structures sociales, même pour les sociétés
préhistoriques. Voilà son cheval de bataille.
Et pour faire cela, il faut changer les
techniques de fouille. La méthodologie
qu’il met en place avec ses étudiants
est particulièrement soignée. Il publie
d’ailleurs en 1950 Les fouilles préhistoriques,
techniques et méthodes, un livre qui expose sa
méthode : le décapage horizontal minutieux, pour
dégager des sols d’habitats entiers, et pouvoir
étudier la disposition des vestiges en place. A
l’opposé des techniques de bourrins de l’époque.
1964 est une année chargée pour André
Leroi-Gourhan. Désormais professeur à la Sorbonne,
il publie une théorie générale d’interprétation
de l’art paléolithique dans Les religions de la
Préhistoire. C’est aussi en 1964 qu’il publie son
ouvrage le plus reconnu, Le geste et la parole,
une synthèse magistrale de ses travaux théoriques.
Et c’est toujours en 1964 qu’il commence la
fouille du site préhistorique de Pincevent.
C’est à Pincevent que Leroi-Gourhan a
l’opportunité de démontrer toute l’excellence
de sa méthode du décapage horizontal. Grâce
aux relevés topographiques systématiques, il
relève les agencements des différentes cabanes,
la position des foyers, et les activités
du quotidien des chasseurs paléolithiques.
Pincevent permet enfin une véritable ethnologie
préhistorique, qu’il appelait de ses vœux.
En 1969 il entre au collège de France et y
donne pendant treize ans un cours sur l’art
paléolithique. Mais malade de Parkinson,
il s’affaiblit assez vite dans les années
1970. Il s’efface progressivement de la
fouille de Pincevent, qui continue sans
lui et qu’il visite souvent. Il prend sa retraite
universitaire en 1982 et meurt finalement à 74 ans
en février 1986. Sa volonté de renouveler les
méthodes et de croiser les approches ont très
durablement marqué les sciences humaines.
Née à Paris en 1928, Michelle Perrot vient d’un
milieu bourgeois. Elle étudie dans une pension
catholique mais son père est particulièrement
libéral et souhaite que sa fille se cultive et
soit indépendante. Elle étudie l’histoire à la
Sorbonne après-guerre, et lit Deuxième sexe de
Simone de Beauvoir dès sa sortie en 1949. Cette
lecture l’inspire beaucoup et Perrot propose à
son professeur Ernest Labrousse de faire son
mémoire de recherche sur le féminisme. Mais
Labrousse la dissuade en lui prédisant qu’elle ne
ferait “pas carrière avec ça” et l’oriente vers
l’histoire sociale, plus en vogue à l’université.
L’étude du monde ouvrier marque donc le premier
temps de son travail. Perrot y apporte une vision
particulière, elle s’attache notamment aux gestes
et aux discours, et publie sa thèse, Les Ouvriers
en grève. Donner une histoire à la classe ouvrière
est pour elle une manière de la rejoindre et de
lutter, malgré ses origines sociales. Ce travail
participe d’un courant très large et elle n’est
pas vraiment une pionnière dans ce domaine. C’est
le cas en revanche pour ses autres objets d’étude.
Car Michelle Perrot est en parallèle l’une des
premières historiennes à s’intéresser aux
prisons. Elle publie Délinquance et système
pénitentiaire en France au xixe siècle en 1975,
la même année que Surveiller et punir de Michel
Foucault. Mais Michelle Perrot est aussi et
surtout connue pour son travail sur les femmes.
L’éclatement de l’Université de Paris après 1968
la conduit à enseigner à l’université Paris VII,
à Jussieu. Et c’est là qu’elle peut organiser
avec Pauline Schmidt et Fabienne Bock, en 1973
le séminaire « Les femmes ont-elles une histoire
? ». C’est tout simplement le premier cours sur
l’histoire de femmes à l’université en France.
Dans les années qui suivent, d’autres cours
se créent à Aix-Marseille ou à Toulouse et Perrot
explore d’autres thématiques comme « Femmes et
famille », « Femmes et travail » ou encore
« Histoire des féminismes ». Contrairement
à la prédiction de son professeur, c’est bien
l’histoire des femmes qui la fait connaître.
C’est celle qui attire le plus d'étudiants et
d’étudiantes, sans doute parce qu’elle répond
à une question plus largement partagée et
souvent existentielle. Perrot fait aussi
toute sa place au concept de genre lorsqu’il
s’impose en France depuis les Etats-Unis.
Mais Perrot ne veut pas faire une histoire
des femmes qui soit uniquement celle de leur
domination, d’autant qu’elle reconnaît le
travail de Françoise Héritier par exemple
pour en démêler les ressorts. Concrètement, cela
se traduit par l’étude de vies individuelles,
dont elle veut dévoiler l’expérience sensible.
Vies de femmes illustres comme Georges Sand ou
d’inconnues comme Lucie Baud, une ouvrière de
la soie. Elle dirige aussi avec Georges Duby
une Histoire des femmes en Occident, une somme
de cinq volumes publiés entre 1990 et 1991.
On peut en fait comprendre le travail de
Michelle Perrot comme la volonté de donner
la parole à ceux qui en ont été privés. Les trois
sujets d’étude qui ont été les siens, ouvriers,
détenus et femmes partagent un statut secondaire
et ont longtemps été gommés de l’histoire par
les grands événements. Son travail s’est
donc attaché à révéler les modalités de
leur exclusion, à explorer comme elle le dit
« le continent perdu des vies englouties ».
Faire ça, c’est bien sûr un acte militant,
qui révèle l’exclusion qui existe toujours.
Et Michelle Perrot continue à 90 ans passés, de
donner des conférences, de s’exprimer dans la
presse comme lors du mouvement #MeToo par exemple.
En vulgarisant son travail à la radio ou en
enregistrant des versions audio de ses livres,
elle a essayé de rendre accessible ses recherches
au plus grand nombre.
Conclusion
Pfffiouuu… C’est la fin de notre petit marathon,
ou de notre sprint plutôt, des intellectuels
français. Alors on aurait pu en choisir d’autres,
on en a d’ailleurs évoqué certains, Auguste Comte,
Marcel Mauss, Michel Foucault ou encore
Françoise Héritier, mais il fallait se
limiter. Je vous cache pas que ça a d’ailleurs
été assez frustrant de couper pas mal d’éléments
pour tenir le format. Mais même si on a fait
qu’effleurer leurs idées, j’espère que ça aura
pu donner envie à certains d’aller creuser un
peu. Je vous rappelle qu’on fait une lecture
de quelques passages de leurs œuvres dans un
live Instagram et qu’on pourra échanger sur
les textes les plus abordables pour commencer,
les critiques qu’on peut leur faire, etc. Sinon
tous les ouvrages sont dans la barre d’info.
Merci à Enodo pour avoir sponsorisé l’épisode.
Je vous rappelle que le jeu The Architect :
Paris est disponible en ce moment sur Steam,
si vous voulez repeindre le Collège de France,
agrandir les universités, et mettre un totem
améridien à la place de la colonne Vendôme,
c’est le jeu qu’il vous faut. A la prochaine.